People often ask me just how dire I think
the state of free speech in America.
In the last two weeks I've spoken at several
college campuses in California, Arizona, and
Texas, as well as attended a conference in
Dallas primarily focused on free speech from
an academic perspective.
I spoke to dozens of professors who feel the
ability to truly exchange ideas or express
unpopular opinions on their campus is at uniquely
perilous cross roads.
The university of Berkley, once the home for
the free speech movement in this country,
quite literally went up in flames when Milo
spoke there.
People with fairly moderate opinions like
professor Jordan Petersen and historian Charles
Murray are shouted down by self righteous
students on college campuses.
Ann Coulter was first barred by Berkely, and
then told she could only speak on a day when
students weren't having classes on campus.
These safe spaces and trigger warnings...concepts
designed to protect feelings instead of dealing
with facts...coupled with constant smearing
of any intellectual opponents as racists or
bigots, has birthed a generation who are increasingly
intolerant of tolerance.
I should also be clear here -- it really is
one side who's being far more intolerant on
campuses today.
Just think, if any college campus invited
a far Left Marxist or Communist who wanted
to end capitalism and ultimately destroy the
United States, there would be virtually no
outcry.
The Marxists and Communists would have their
event, with maybe a few curious people challenging
their ideas during a Q&A, and that would be
it.
The absolute reverse is happening all over
the country when a conservative -- or any
non-Leftist speakers -- are invited to college
campuses.
Ben Shapiro has been banned from DePaul for
sharing his brand of mainstream conservative
thought.
Antifa, the self proclaimed anti facists,
who actually use facist tactics to silence
their opponents, and who dress like Cobra
soldiers from GI Joe, issued a statement and
threatened to protest Portland State when
Christina Hoff Sommers, Peter Boghhosian and
I spoke there.
Apparently they found something more anti
LGBTQ and anti women right before we started,
so they moved their protests elsewhere.
And of course, as I always say and will continue
to say, you have every right to protest and
use your speech to counter someone else's
speech.
What you don't have a right to do is silence
someone else by using violence or intimidation.
This is why I talk so much about self-censorship
and chill effect around free speech.
Violence not only silences the speakers of
today, but in essence it silences the speakers
of tomorrow who will quiet themselves instead
of dealing with the protests and smears and
everything else that comes with being someone
outside of group think.
What's being stolen from these college students
is the ability to learn how to think about
complex issues while in university, so they
can be equipped to engage with diverse set
of ideas in the real real world.
And that diversity, diversity of thought is
far more important that diversity of immutable
characteristics be it race relgion or sexuality.
Last week I spoke at University of Arizona
with my friend and former guest Michael Shermer.
It turned out that there was a trans holocaust
denier in the crowd.
Yes, trans holocaust deniers do exist.
Not only did we not silence her, but we opened
up the floor for her to ask us questions.
Michael, the editor in Chief of Skeptic magazine,
who specializes in debunking conspiracy theories,
an expert in debunking holocaust denial myths,
answered her questions clearly and with facts.
The students in the room didn't attack her
or kick her out despite her abhorrent beliefs.
It was a truly beautiful moment which shows
why free speech is so important.
We exercised our right to talk openly at a
public event in which anyone was welcome to
join, as she shared her ideas, which we countered
with better ideas.
While I suspect Michael didn't change her
mind on holocaust denial, we put our principles
of free expression to the test.
This open discussion with a wide array of
opinion is how you expand knowledge and figure
out what you believe, NOT by silencing, shaming,
and defaming your ideological opponent.
Sadly, the true tolerance that we experienced
in that room is a rarity on college these
days.
I know I don't have to sell you guys on the
lunacy that's happening at college campuses.
You see it everyday with the language police
telling people what pronouns to use, or else!,
and the endless stream of insane stories coming
from America's campuses showing how intolerant
the so called "tolerant side" has become.
What I would like to focus on here, is the
creeping groupthink an obfuscation around
free thought free speech that is no creeping
up into the political echelon.
Just this week you may have seen new Democratic
National Committee chairman Tom Perez say
the DNC won't back any politicians who aren't
pro-choice.
While I have no problem with the party having
a set of beliefs as a guideline for its policies,
this type of intolerance to other ideas, even
if they're incredibly difficult topics like
abortion, set a terrible precedent for the
exchange of ideas in a pluralistic society.
This specific event isn't a direct threat
to free speech, but it does go to the heart
of how intolerance by the Left is driving
otherwise liberal people, to the center.
Or, as the Left calls it, the neo nazi alt
right white suprmacist far right.
The more egregious assault on free speech
in the last few days though was from former
head of the DNC and former Presidential candidate
Howard Dean.
Dean is a progressive who at this point really
sums up why this ideology is not truly for
progression of freedom and liberalism, but
for regression of them.
After hearing that Ann Coulter was going to
be banned from Berkely, Dean claimed that
Coulter's hate speech was not protected by
the first amendment.
IMAGE: https://twitter.com/RubinReport/status/855450593715945473
"Ann Coulter's Hate Speech is not protected
by the first Amendment."
Well actually Howard, it is.
100%.
Absolutely.
Full stop.First off, he uses the amorphous
term 'hate speech' sounds like something but
doesn't actually exist.
Yes, you can't call for direct violence to
a person or a group, that's a criminal offense,
but you are allowed to say hateful and mean
things.
That's the very part of free speech that we
have to protect because the definition of
hate speech will just keep expanding until
it includes any speech that the veers ever
so slightly away from group think.
Beyond Dean's confusion about hate speech,
he also apparently doesn't know what the first
Amendment is.
As I know you know, the first Amendment is
about prohibiting the government from making
any laws prohibiting free speech, it has absolutely
nothing to do with the speech of a private
person, or hate speech, or a university deplatforming
a speaker.
If you truly care about minorities, college
Republicans ARE a minority in most universities,
and they deserve to be heard from, just like
anyone else who has been offered a platform.
Sadly, Dean is a progressive thought leader
while he seemingly has no idea about the very
constitution our political leaders are supposed
to defend.
With this is mind, I still absolutely believe
the best way to beat the violent tactics of
Antifa or the intellectually challenged ideas
of Howard Dean, is to counter them with better
ideas.
We shouldn't stoop to their level of violence,
or try to take away their free speech.
We should teach the ideas of liberty, freedom,
and true liberalism.
Yes, they'll always scream louder than us,
or act out more hysterically, but I believe
our game is a long one and our better ideas
will win if we actually put them into practice.
With this in mind, we're continuing our partnership
with Learn Liberty this week with Brandon
Turner, a professor of political science and
George Mason University.
He's an expert in political theory, with extensive
knowledge of the writings of everyone from
John Stuart Mill to Karl Marx.
We're going to explore political thinkers
from all across the map to see which ideas
stand the test of time.
Right or left, democrat or Republican, male
or female, gay or straight, every single issue
starts with our ability to discuss it and
figure out what we believe.
If we can unite against the forces that will
silence us we may find allies in places we
never thought we would.